We have to admit there's something
insidious and detestable about late
night television,
the kind of vicious circle.
It's hard to realize until you actually
go to a taping and the warmup comedian
gauges your laugh on a one to 10 volume
scale and instructs you that you're only
at about a seven and you need to keep it
up and turn it up for every little joke
you're about to see because the
microphones are way up in the ceiling
and they won't hear you otherwise.
It begins to dawn on you after about 10
cheerless guffaws that you came to the
taping because you thought the show was
funny and you thought the show was funny
because all the jokes were followed by
maps and cheers and the lapse in cheers
we're forced to make are what's causing
the audience at home.
To think the show is funny and it's why
they want to come to the taping
themselves,
which they do and they laugh and the
cycle begins.
Again,
disappointing as this is.
It's also truly absurd.
A self generating observed that appears
normal to us because it's all we know
and if a really smart and innovative
comedian wanted to draw attention to the
normalization of this absurd American
ritual,
perhaps the first thing to do would be
to grab hold of the absurdity and turn
it way.
Oh,
that's the biggest job I've ever seen
and I don't think this is the right.
We're going to keep going with this and
we're going to see when we hit the
pixelation,
the only unmarried looking for love life
was passing me by,
so I sent off my four two hobbies and
age magazine,
marriage.
I try to read his lovely Japanese girls
have been trained in the art of fees in
men.
Be Lonely,
no more open destinies for $1.
They arrange a meeting for 10 years
years.
The brilliant Craig Ferguson has lit a
fire from within the late night talk
show universe.
Systematically deconstructing all its
elements,
whether it's the deferential sidekick,
the live band,
with the pre interview.
More than any,
the preinterview means nothing.
It means nothing.
It's meaningless.
The pre interviews a formality like
wearing a tie or underpants,
it seemed like the biggest enemy to
Ferguson sense of comedy was the very
foundation of late night TV structure
itself.
Ferguson.
We sought out the unrehearsed,
the spontaneous.
He encouraged the awkward,
the weird,
the difficult to know.
We should start rehearsing and recognize
and despise late nights deification of
celebrity and took every opportunity to
mock us for buying into it.
I mean,
it's a short time on this planet,
man.
It's a date and then a hyphen
and then another day and we have the
hyphen and I'm like,
I'm not spending the whole time talking
celebrities.
Now this isn't to say that
that hosts like Jimmy Fallon,
who I do like is somehow bankrupt
because all he does is pay homage to the
format by putting it in terms young
people of today can understand.
It's just that he and Ferguson sit at
opposite ends of the spectrum or rather
ferguson more than anyone else.
Willingly places himself outside the
spectrum and his relationship to late
night is an altogether different quality
or revolutionary one.
Americans not here.
You're going to lift the Dragon Tattoo.
The tension between
Ferguson and late night was what made
Ferguson so funny.
His ability to express contempt for his
position,
his network,
his job,
his willingness to admit his failures to
dwell on it was for many of us,
extremely liberating,
and that's because late night tv is a
fantasy,
a fantasy of sophistication,
charm and fun.
A standard to which after enough time we
hold ourselves unwittingly.
No one knew this better than Craig
Ferguson for 10 fucking awesome fucking
weird years.
He tried to show us that life bears far
less resemblance to a string of funny
stories than to the long awkward pauses
that exists between,
well,
I hope we've done is.
It is maybe a to maybe art is a very
grand word,
but,
but what I was trying to do here and
what I think that we've managed to do
here,
make something that wasn't here before
all I like,
I like chocolate milk.
Chocolate.
Dark chocolate is in.
You didn't lie.
You didn't want them.
You didn't want to.
Robot someone who creates them his own
chocolate.